how about now we say rather than Zen
school between daughter- 22
how about let's have a cheering let's go
between 2 & 3 can you how to go that
yourself without me helping you trying
to work out use this diagram to help you
where is it that you're looking and
therefore what percentage you would get
and what you expect - you haven't think
about that ok just like we did before I
think the thing that will help you much
to work out not just what the number is
but also work out if you can be
convinced and virgins is the picture
itself the picture itself so between 2 &
3 where is that one the picture
it's this last little black area degree
so this is the spot I'm off time okay so
all I need to do is work out how big is
that little strip there that's all
laughter okay now we know if we went all
the way out all the way up we have 99.7
that's what this says and if we go to
backwards one step backwards like that
that'll give us about this but blue
black area - do you hear that it's only
six so let's just quickly work that out
I'm even gonna write up both areas from
plus or minus two that's where I'm
healed 3 2 plus or minus 3
okay that's what I'm about to calculate
so the widest I can go is 97 but if I go
in one step that's 95 yes so
99.7 take away 95 what's that give you
wait seven now just pause for a moment
does that make sense does do you expect
to get four points that's a really small
percentage do you expect to get that
small petrol engine idea you should
because that's the whole point of the
normal distribution and the further you
go out the less and less of the
population again that makes sense
okay but I even have in my work you that
I said both areas plus or minus 2 plus
or minus 3 I don't I just don't let them
see but do you see realize what you're
gonna die right you're not give me this
cuz I showed you the number because I
have worked in that way you see the
logic okay so therefore once I said but
there is now I'm gonna say one area
from plus 2 to plus 3 now I know which
side I'm talking about it's going to be
exactly half of the area I worked at the
pole because it's perfectly symmetrical
which is 2.35 yeah thank you